- [Narrator] Although the
Spanish were the first
European colonists in the New World,
they didn't remain alone in
the Americas for very long.
Just three years after Hernan
Cortes captured Tenochtitlan,
the French government
sent its first explorer
to poke around North America
and look for what many European explorers
had searched for from the beginning,
a passage to the East.
Now, although the explorers never found
this Northwest passage
because it didn't exist,
they, like the Spanish, quickly learned
that there were quite a
lot of riches to be had
in the Americas themselves.
In this video, I'd like to
take some time to talk about
two of the lesser known European
colonies in the New World,
New France up here in pink
and New Netherland, this
little orange dot right here.
Now, you can see that compared
to the extent of New Spain,
here in the Caribbean and Mexico
and expanding in South America,
these colonial exploits
were pretty small indeed,
but I think it's important to
learn a little bit about them
because they help us see the ways
in which the different
goals of colonial powers
led to very different types
of settlement in the New World
and very different relationships
between Europeans and Native Americans.
Now, though it's a little
bit hard to see on this map,
these two colonies focused
their efforts around two rivers,
the Saint Lawrence River
and the Hudson River
which runs along this
little orange strip here.
And along these rivers,
you can still see the
cities that were founded
by these colonial ventures
like Quebec City up in Canada,
later Montreal and down here
of course the most famous
which started as New Amsterdam
and later became the city of New York.
Right about here is
the Island of Manhattan
on which New York City,
formerly New Amsterdam, is located.
Now, looking at this
map, you might wonder,
why was it that Spain have
these giant swabs of territory
really from coast to coast
where New France and New Netherland
really only followed along these rivers,
at least to start with?
And the answer really lies
in this idea of goals.
And New France and New
Netherland sat on the rivers,
rivers being the highways of the world
really up until the
invention of the railroad,
because they were primarily
interested in trade.
So let's talk a little
bit more about that.
French and Dutch explorers
were particularly interested
in gaining valuable furs to
trade from Native Americans
living in the Northern
part of North America
that they could then sell in Europe.
Long before European colonization began,
beavers had been hunted pretty
much to extinction in Europe
while beaver pelts
themselves were usually used
to create fancy hats.
This is a hat from a slightly later era,
but you can get the sense here
that Europeans met on
something of an equal basis
with Native Americans in the
process of the fur trade,
so Europeans wanted beaver pelts
and also the pelts of other
animals and often fish,
another thing that was in great supply
in this Northern region which is today
the Northeast United States and Canada.
So how did this focus on
trade affect the relationships
between Europeans and Native
Americans in the area?
Well, primarily they made
relationships between them
considerably friendlier
and more cooperative
than the relationships between the Spanish
and Native Americans for example.
Now, Europeans quickly discovered
that it made a lot more sense
to instead of sending hundreds
upon hundreds of Frenchmen to Canada
to hunt beavers themselves,
they could instead pay Native Americans
to hunt the beavers for them.
And consequently, there
were considerably fewer
French and Dutch settlers in
New Netherland and New France
than there were in New Spain.
And because there were fewer of them,
they generally ended up doing things
more on the terms of Native Americans
so whereas the Spanish
might have used their guns
and their war dogs to
force Native Americans
to labor for them,
the French and the Dutch
were more likely to observe
trading rituals like giving gifts
and also fostering trade relationships
through intermarriage.
French traders learned
the Algonquian language
and married native women
and had children with them
so that they could be
considered part of the family.
They even allied with
Native American Tribes
against their own enemies
and went to war with them
as in the case in 1609
when French explorer Samuel de Champlain
helped Algonquians in their
war against the Iroquois.
And like New France,
New Netherland situated as it
was in this very good harbor,
the Island of Manhattan, was
likewise very focused on trade.
In fact, New Amsterdam was a
little bit of a company town
controlled by the Dutch West India Company
which sought to make the
most of all of the goodies
that could be brought from North America
and then shipped to Europe.
In fact, you can get a sense
of what the major concerns
of the Europeans settling in
this area were from this map.
You can see that they point
out where beavers, turkeys,
foxes, and bears can be found
all with their valuable pelts,
but you also see that
there's an extremely detailed
rendering of where many
Native American Tribes lived
like this detailed
rendering of what I believe
is a Mahican village.
The French and Dutch bothered
to learn all of these names
and map all of this territory
because they cooperated
with the Native Americans
to get these pelts.
It's hard to imagine a Spanish map
that would go into such
detail about native villages.
It's important to remember
that Europeans were
competing with each other
for resources in the New World
hoping that they could secure
the best trade deals for furs
with Native Americans
and prevent other nations
from securing those furs.
For example, the Dutch
allied with the Iroquois
in the New World as trading partners
because the Iroquois were
the long-time enemies
of the Algonquians who were
allied with the French.
So just as the Europeans
recruited Native Americans
into their competitions to
supply Europe with furs,
Native Americans recruited Europeans
into their inter-tribal feuds
to supply the Americas
with European goods.
I wanna finish by just briefly comparing
each nation's colonial
goals with their outcomes
and what sorts of people settled,
what the relationships were
like with Native Americans,
and even how they
attempted or didn't attempt
to convert Native Americans
to a form of Christianity.
Now, as we saw with Spain,
their goal was to quickly
extract natural resources
from the Americas and
to set up plantations
for tobacco and later sugar,
plus to convert as many of the
native people to Catholicism
as possible by force if necessary
and it was frequently necessary.
Consequently, most of the Spanish settlers
who came to the New World
were men and adventurers
who treated native people with
violence and enslaved them
in the encomienda system
and in some cases had
relationships with native women
and African women that resulted
in that very complex set
of racial designations we
see in the caste system.
But France and the Netherlands
by contrast came for trade.
They wanted furs and fish
and so they were very careful
to cultivate very friendly relationships
with Native Americans including
by intermarrying with them
in a deliberate and formal way
so that they could take
advantage of having natives
do the hunting for them
rather than having to do it themselves
so that really only a few men
came to New France and New Netherland,
nothing like the numbers of Spain.
And unlike the Spanish,
although the French did attempt
to convert natives to Catholicism,
they rarely did so by force.
Now, going forward as we talk
about British colonization
in the next few lessons,
I want you to keep both the Spanish
and the French and Dutch modes
of colonization in your mind
so you can compare and
contrast English colonization
with both of them.
And as we'll see,
the goals of the various English colonies
whether it's to found plantations
like in Jamestown, Virginia,
or to escape religious persecution
like in Massachusetts Bay,
that goal will go on to influence
not only who came to the
Americas from Europe,
but also their relationships
with native people.